so if you're currently unemployed here's
what you got to do
number one is you got to apply you got
to apply at your state
department of labor website and that's
where you get started boom
so now every state has different
qualifications so
in texas florida and pennsylvania they
got qualifications like
you need to be actively seeking work in
order to qualify for unemployment
and then you can't refuse what's called
meaningful work whatever that means
that's number one number two if you're
collecting unemployment benefits how
long does that last now usually it lasts
12 to 30 weeks but with part of the
cares act they said
listen buddy we're going to add another
13 weeks onto unemployment benefits
not so bad so they're there for you
they're giving you money number three
food snap this used to be called food
stamps you can apply for that there's
local food banks there's local food
programs let me tell you something when
it comes to unemployment and when it
comes to food
you should have no shame in your game
these are programs to help you eat
live and survive have no shame in your
game let me tell you something i talk
about money i'm a 40 year old man right
now let me tell you something when i was
23 and i lost my first job
i collected unemployment i collected
food stamps
no shame in your game all right go get
that money number four now you got to
start your job search are you looking
for full time are you looking for
part-time you're looking for a
completely new
opportunity you got to start your job
search if you're going to start your job
search
well you better have a resume here's an
example of a resume that we brought up
for you of a great candidate
jobby mcjob face looking good number two
you got to reach out to job recruiters
number three you gotta
update your linkedin profile these are
things you need to do in order to start
finding
some work update that linkedin profile
so the number one question that a new
job will ask you is
this how did you improve during covit
you better have an answer for that how
did covet change your thought process
you better have an answer for that you
better prepare for this line of
questioning every job is going to ask
you these type of questions
so there's a hot tip for you number five
work on your skills why because skills
pay the bills here we go so you got to
be making sure that you're focusing on
careers or jobs that are in demand right
like if no one's hiring for what you
want to do
you got to pivot so make sure that
you're working on in demand job skills
there's free online college courses tons
of them coursera
harvard yale they're offering free
online courses check them out
categories like coding data science
leadership
free classes free courses focus on that
understand that you might be working
remote
understand what zoom is slack different
things like that
technologically that can advance your
career all right you can intern you can
volunteer
you can fill that resume so you look
good and if you're thinking about
becoming an entrepreneur well you've
come to the right place baby on
valuetainment there's
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
videos explaining all the things that
you need to know
about becoming an entrepreneur and
number six very underrated don't forget
about your mental health there's a lot
of time staying at home right now
maybe you're not talking to people if
you're having problems
talk it out you can do yoga you can
meditate physical exercise
you're not alone make sure that your
mental health is positive
and that you're not going down a
negative path all right so what does it
all come down to well
check this things are very unclear right
now we know that but what
is clear what is clear is that there are
certain steps that you can take
you that you can take to better position
yourself for the future
so the question is this will you be
prepared
[Music]
you